dans la foulée des attentats à paris le
premier ministre britannique david
cameron songe à interdire des
applications de discussion instantanée
qui utilisent la cryptographie et dont
le contenu donc ne peut pas être lu par
les agences de renseignement une
déclaration qui a fait bondir autant les
défenseurs de la vie privée que le monde
des affaires où sont mathieu
l'enseignement de vous retrouver alors
expliquez nous d'abord ce que c'est la
cryptographie comment est-ce qu'on
définisse à la cryptographie les
talonneurs actuellement dans le fameux
film d imitation game qui met en vedette
robin et des combles batch dans leur
rôle d'alan turing donc mathématicien
britannique qui avec son équipe a réussi
à briser les codes la machine enigma des
nazis donc la cryptographie c'est la
capacité convenant à traduire un message
sur internet en une entité indices ich
indéchiffrable pour qu'ils ne peuvent ne
possède pas une clé donc quelqu'un qui à
l'arrivée de ce message le passé d'une
clip all le traduire en langage en
langage courant
et qu'est ce qui inquiète tant david
cameron est d'en écouter c'est parce que
dans la foulée de la sphère snowdon y de
plus en plus de compagnies pas les
moyens qui offre des solutions de
chiffrement extrêmement facile alors on
pense par exemple à facebook
snap chat whatsapp gmail il est même
montréalais nadim kobeissi qui est mis
en ligne récemment un service qui
s'appelle peyo et qui permet de
rivaliser avec ce qui jusqu'à maintenant
étaient l'apanage seulement des débits
pirates informatiques alors c'est aussi
facile à utiliser qu'un service de
courriel sauf que c'est absolument
impossible de déchiffrer par des tiers
et c'est maintenant à la portée de tout
le monde
oui c'est ça et sinon ce serait pour
déjouer d'éventuels complots terroristes
la paix que tu avais commun veut faire
sécession effectivement monsieur tout le
monde a accès à sa mévente mais aussi
les terroristes et donc il a déclaré
qu'il n'hésiterait pas dans le cas où ce
réélu en mai prochain à
interdire plusieurs applications de
discussion instantanée
si les services de sécurité britanniques
n'arrivais pas à avoir accès à ces
communications là donc c'est quand même
assez groupe
donc on peut comprendre mais est-ce que
c'est souhaitable une part et est-ce que
c'est réalisable surtout bon mais
plusieurs analystes qui disent que ce
serait premièrement extrêmement
difficile à réaliser cette espèce de
blocus cryptographique de l'angleterre
et d'autre part si jamais évident quand
même réussi c'est avec une politique
telle politique en ligne
ça mettrait en danger selon plusieurs
analystes la l'économie britannique même
pas ce que l'on peut imaginer parce que
la cryptographie fait partie de la
puissance économique d'une nation la
capacité qu'on a à garder des secrets
industriels des secret bancaire ça fait
partie d'une économie forte et donc si
un pays comme l'angleterre devenait
privé d'une certaine le stun l'accès à
la cryptographie
il ya même des gens comme le magazine
forbes qu'un prédit un avenir très
sombre pour l'économie britannique parce
que des grosses compagnies pourraient
carrément décidé de quitter l'angleterre
parce que ne serait pas en mesure de
garder leurs données secrètes et l'on
parle de banque
on parle de grandes compagnies
informatiques alors ça pourrait être une
apocalypse économique pour l'angleterre
si jamais une telle politique devenait
en vigueur donc si vous dites au fond
c'est que les états sont un peu
condamnés à vivre avec ces données
chiffrées là c'est un jeu du chat et de
la souris la cryptographie depuis
qu'elle existe à grande échelle et on
doit vivre avec le fait que maintenant
nos discussions peuvent être un peu plus
privée et que les états doivent
maintenant compter avec des gens qui
développent des solutions comme ça ça
fait là faire de nous des fois moins des
agences de renseignement mais pour le
biais de l'économie et de nos vies
privées
il faut peut-être être habitué à vivre
avec ça de renner et oui alors merci
beaucoup mathieu au plaisir